ابدا معك هشام ربما لتضيف بعض التفاصيل
التي ربما لم ترد في التقرير الذي تابعناه
للتو تفضل وصل اللهم على محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه وسلم ليلى القصف الاسرائيلي على رفح
ربما عندما نتحدث عنه فان له خصوصيه فرفح
هي المكان الاكثر اكتظاظا ربما في قطاع
غزه وربما في العالم في هذه الفتره لا سما
وان الجيش الاسرائيلي يطلب من سكان قطاع
غزه ان توجهوا الى رفح اذا دخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي في عمليه توغل في اي منطقه من
المناطق فانه يطلب من السك يطلب من السكان
ان يتوجهوا الى رفح وبالتحديد الى حي تل
السلطان ومخيم الشابوره وبعد ذلك يقصف
خلال الايام الماضيه نحن نرصد عده غارات
تستهدف مدينه رفح نرصد قصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي للخيام في مدينه رفح خيام
النازحين فما بالك بهذه المنازل في ظل هذا
البرد القارس وهذه الاجواء فان السكان من
يجد له منزل او شقه سكنيه في مدينه رفح
فهو انه ربما يكون الاكثر حظا وبالتالي
القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف منزلا في مخيم
الشابوره وبالتاكيد هذا المنزل كان مكتظا
عن بكره ابيه قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه هذا المنزل دمرت اجزاء كبيره
منه وبالتالي كان هناك داد من الشهداء
والجرحى واذا رصدنا هؤلاء الشهداء فنحن
نجد ان هؤلاء الشهداء هم من الاطفال ومن
النساء وعشرات الاصابات هم من النساء
والاطفال فاذا القصف الاسرائيلي اي قصف
اسرائيلي على رفح نحن نتحدث عن عشرات من
الشهداء نتحدث عن عشرات من الشهداء
والجرحى وهناك من المفقودين وبالتالي حتى
طواقم الاسعاف طواقم الدفاع المدني تواجه
صعوبه في الوصول الى تلك المناطق
المستهدفه لان الازدحام كبير الناس تتواجد
على الارصفه تتواجد على في الشوارع نصبوا
خياما في كل مكان في مدينه رفح وبالتالي
اي قصف اسرائيلي على المدينه بالتاكيد
سيحدث اضرار كبيره دبار كبير وخساره كبيره
في هذه المباني التي بكل تاكيد يلجا اليها
السكان وهي الملجا الوحيد الان اليهم في
ظل هذه الاعداد الكبيره من السكان 300000
نسمه كان عدد سكان رفح اليوم هم مليون
و300 ال نسمه في ظل ايضا مزيد من النزوح
في ظل ايضا مزيد من الاستهدافات في
خانيونس وفي دير البلح وفي العديد من
المناطق ايضا المناطق الشرقيه لرفح تتعرض
ما بين الفينه والاخرى الى قصف مدفعي عنيف
من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه في
تلك المناط المناطق الغربيه تعرضت صباح
هذا اليوم وعلى مدار الايام الماضيه الى
قصف من الزوارق الحربيه الاسرائيليه اذا
هو قصف مكثف على هذه المدينه التي باتت
مكتظه والتي يلجا اليها الناس الحدود
جميعها ممتلئه بالخيام الشوارع ممتلئه
بالخيام الارصفه ممتلئه بالخيام والمنازل
المدنيه بكل تاكيد هي ملجا السكان في ظل
هذه الاوضاع والاحوال الجويه السيئه